um okay I wanna I wanna say one more
thing about Adam 22.
okay you cannot live a life
trying to drag you into it without all
of these degenerate crazy people trying
to and this is what they'll do they'll
attack you personally they'll dig into
your past they'll they'll dig for any
piece of dirt they can find on you and
what they'll do is they'll try to bring
you into this degeneracy and the crazy
thing is I just want to know how much
they're making off of this because I
want to know what amount of money was
worth it to you one amount of money was
worth this like degeneracy and I bet you
this becomes a pattern like how many n
is he gonna give his wife to in the next
year it's not gonna end it's